71 of high school dropouts are from  single mother homes okay 70 of use in  operated institutions are from single  mother homes eighty percent of use in  prison are from single mother homes 85  percent of children who show behavioral  disorders are from single mother homes  right and eighty percent of children  with anger issues  are from single mother homes  you're saying you want to be a single  mother essentially when and if I read  you these stats and what it's going to  be like for your child generally you  might be the you might hang on to say oh  but it says 80 which means I might be  under 20 I'm an exception you haven't  accepted to the rule but the rule looks  like this so let me are you winning are  you willing to put your child so at this  statistical disappointment no no no  answer this question yeah